values and ethics come long before you
actually need them so if that guy was
taking care of his business he would
have been in enough abundance to tell
that woman to kick rocks so much so that
he would have easily traded out the sex
for how proud he was of the honor that
he showed to his friend and many men
cannot do that and many friendships Get
Wrecked
over a divorce or a breakup that ends up
with some guy
[__] his buddy over he's been friends
with him for 20 years because he doesn't
work hard enough on himself to have
women of his own and so no I don't trust
a man that does a good women and I
certainly don't trust a man that doesn't
have money because it will come up and
he will [__] you not because he's a bad
man because he's a desperate man